[Música]
se trata de una perla de Esmeralda
frente a roscof la isla de Bach una
tierra de unos cuantos kilómetros
cuadrados en la que Residen al año 507
habitantes
isleños que viven del turismo o de la
agricultura en un lugar excepcional
frente al mar
esta casa con contraventanas azules es
una institución en la isla para Los
viajeros del continente
una habitación de huésped manejada por
esta agricultora retirada
yogures hechos en casa usted los prepara
Sí con la leche de las vacas de la isla
de Bach
con el fermento son un éxito a la gente
les gusta
aquí todo está hecho para que Los
viajeros se sientan como en casa
entonces cuando se viene una vez es
inevitable volver
esta joven pareja ha venido por algunos
días no es la primera vez pero no se
cansan
entonces Hoy hay una Vista Hermosa para
ver hacia el faro
el mar está picado
amagy Pierre le gusta a Los
visitantes porque ello le permite darle
vida a la casa de sus ancestros y padre
mi abuelo y mi bisabuelo vivieron aquí
bueno así que aquí hay un espacio que ha
permanecido más o menos en cambios
con el mobiliario de la época y en
especial la cama de sus abuelos
14 hijos de estos abuelos una dama de
roskov y un hombre de la isla de Bach
los niños son menos numerosos en la isla
hoy en día el colegio cuenta con tan
solo 16 alumnos y los profesores son
itinerantes
vengo dos días a la semana porque los
otros días Estoy en la lista sana son
cuentas horas de clase
que tomo la embarcación de las 18 horas
profesores polivalente enseña entre
sexto y octavo
Buenos días vamos a corregir el examen
primera hora de clase de biología para
el grupo de séptimo les doy sus hojas lo
que Les propongo es que se ubiquen en
grupos de dos
cuarentín Hazte con Lucy Qué otros
equipos no sé Jose con Alice si
necesitan moverse para hablar pueden
hacerse un poco más alejados es rápido
teniendo en cuenta los equipos rápido
siendo 5 se aprende mejor y pues los
resultados son mejores
[Música]
mientras que los niños construyen Su
futuro otros trabajan la Tierra
batch es un territorio fértil en el que
los agricultores cultivan la
especialidad de La Isla la papa con
algas un trabajo duro que no deja mucho
tiempo libre
Sí yo en efecto trabajo más o menos 8 o
9 horas diarias Noel por su parte no
para mucho de 6 a 11 6 de la mañana 11
de la noche
[Aplausos]
un trabajo largo y difícil en materia de
agricultura ecológica para conservar la
tierra de la isla y el embalaje se hacen
familia con sus dos hijos pongo 12
docenas en esta sí
voy a exponer 8 aquí y otras ocho aquí
esta explotación produce 180 toneladas
de papa de tierra ecológica al año una
buena parte es enviada diariamente al
continente transportada en la barcaza de
La Isla que todos los días hace la
travesía hasta roskov
[Música]
El capitán es un Marino de aquí que
nunca quiso irse
usted nunca se fue quiere decir viajar
sí de La Isla sí nos hemos ido pero tres
o cuatro días es lo máximo porque
estamos muy bien en la isla Suárez
desde hace 40 años la barcaza es como un
puente vital para la isla
antes todo se hacía manualmente eran
embarcaciones pequeñas cargaban a granel
en el barco
eran unos 15 los que hacían eso al día y
nosotros con cuatro hombres lo hacemos
todos los días
última embarcación que sale hacia el
continente los turistas se van los
habitantes reencuentran su Isla donde el
tiempo parece no correr